Speaker 1: So we are seeing a trend of more
and more Republicans calling for violence
while claiming that the left is violent, claiming
that they're for law and order, claiming people
must follow the rules, claiming people must
listen to police and all this stuff.
OK, we now have had three what I would consider
prominent calls to violence from notable Republican
figures within the last week or two.
And this is this is just the last.
Again, it's like 10 days or something like
that.
And this is, you know, forget about the fact
that if you visit the right wing pro trump
enclaves of the Internet, it's thousands and
thousands of individuals doing it as well.
I'm focusing here on the fact that there are
prominent semi prominent right wing figures
that are now seemingly comfortable publicly
saying we should do violence, we should dorkus,
we should do insurrections, we should do the
Second Amendment stuff in order to protect
this or to protect that.
OK, let's start.
We looked at this one last week or the week
before.
Fox News propagandist Tucker Carlson calls
for a real insurrection, a real insurrection.
The framing, the ANAO, the illusion they're
being alluding to.
January six wasn't a real insurrection, but
we probably should have a real one.
Remember, this was about completely incorrect
claims about immigration from Tucker's guest.
And this is how that went down, that the
Speaker 4: people coming north from Latin
America, Central America, a lot of cases are
aware that there's a new administration in
the United States and the policies are different.
Oh, most definitely.
They're telegraphing it down to what do you
when you see t shirts with people say, Viva,
let me in, Viva let me.
And they're all over.
I mean, you know, it's telegraphed back down
to one of them comes over and they'll tell
you soon as I get over and get through, I'm
calling back home when I'm selling ten more
to come that I got the end.
Come on.
We're sending a message that, hey, the borders
open.
Come on in, do what you want.
I mean, what and why are we enforcing the
laws that are on the book?
They're already on the book that says you
can't cross the border illegally or whatever.
But yeah, we're going to reward you with putting
you in a nice hotel or or give you a fourteen
hundred dollar Visa card debit card that you
can use while you're here in the States you
get established or whatever.
And how many times they replenish.
You mean give a 14 hour Visa debit card?
I haven't been able to confirm this yet, but
I have told that they're giving you these
immigrant families.
They're in these hotels.
They're giving them a fourteen dollar I mean,
a 14 hour later Visa card.
They think, why don't we have a real insurrection
at some point?
Like why?
Why would we put up with this?
Well, in my opinion, you're closer than you've
ever been in our country of getting to that.
I think we're closer.
I feel closer to that.
I mean, this is absolutely
Speaker 1: it's beyond insulting.
That's the type of thing that.
Is actually illiberal, anti-democratic, authoritarian
escalation that we've been talking about.
That's a perfect example right there.
So there's Tucker Carlson.
Then we had Matt Gates, the beleaguered and
disgusting Congressman Matt Gates said that
we have an obligation.
This was an event a few days ago.
We haven't we they, I guess, have an obligation
to use the Second Amendment in armed rebellion.
They must do it.
Here is Matt Gates.
Speaker 5: The Internet's hall monitors out
in Silicon Valley.
They think they can suppress us, discourage
us.
Maybe if you're just a little less patriotic,
maybe if you just conform to their way of
thinking a little more, then you'll be allowed
to participate in the digital world.
Well, you know what?
Silicon Valley can't cancel this movement
or this rally or this congressman.
Speaker 1: Nice one, right?
I mean, listen, this is the guy who says it's
not OK to cancel someone.
Twitter bands are over the line, but shooting
others dead.
That's OK.
That's a completely different thing.
And that's something that he is going to talk
about.
As Adam Congress as a congressman, Adam Kinzinger
said about that, quote, This is why we need
a January 6th commission.
Four months after an insurrection at the Capitol.
We're hearing this language at another rally
where so-called leaders are stoking fears
and anger and inciting violence.
Adam Kinzinger is completely correct.
And then we have the clip we looked at in
the first segment on today's show, and I'll
play it again for you just to have it all
here together.
Donald Trump's former national security adviser.
Yeah, former national security adviser Michael
Flynn calling for a coup to be done against
Joe Biden at an event on Sunday evening.
Speaker 2: A simple Marine, I want to know
why what happened in Miramar can't happen
here.
Oh.
Speaker 3: You know, the no reason you should
have one more.
Speaker 1: A former national security adviser
calling for the forcible removal of a president
there, I still can't get over M.R.
They don't even know Myanmar, M.R. Minemura,
they don't care what it's called.
They don't need to know anything about it.
As long as they can use it somehow to point
to, we should forcibly remove Joe Biden.
These are calls to violence, period.
That's what they are.
They have to be called what they are, the
movement that insists we have to call things
what they are.
That's them.
Call this what it is.
Just call it what it is.
A sitting congressman attempts to incite acts
of terror.
A former national security adviser encourages
a coup.
One of the most watched right wing propagandist
media hosts adopts the language of January
six and says, let's do it for real.
This time, the January 6th one wasn't really
an insurrection, but how about a real insurrection?
And the right continues to just edge and push
and prod and encourage their people towards
launching some version of what might look
like a civil war.
Now, in all seriousness, maybe not with the
Tucker Carlson example, but certainly with
the Michael Flynn example and the Matt Gates
examples.
Shouldn't the FBI be paying these guys visits?
And I'm not saying the FBI should harass people
or look into people for political reasons.
What I mean is if normal people said this
kind of stuff publicly, it might actually
be something that gets them a visit from law
enforcement or from federal agents.
Why is that?
Not even in the picture when it comes to Michael
Flynn and Matt Gates.
And then, of course, as I mentioned before,
is Michael Flynn getting some kind of pension
from the military?
And if so, don't statements like these call
into question whether he should be receiving
that pension?
And aside from the political piece, they're
saying this stuff as we have just mass shooting
after mass shooting in the United States,
they barely even make headlines anymore.
One big one last week in San Jose did make
headlines.
But in the week prior, I think there were
something like 18, was it 40, 14 or 18 mass
shootings.
Most of I don't know where most of them were.
They don't even make headlines because it's
just constant.
And then here is just another angle on this.
Not necessarily ginning up the person to person
violence.
That often is what we see in mass shootings.
But just generally building up this idea of
let's use violence, let's use violence to
solve personal problems, let's use violence
to solve political problems.
And hey, if we bring guns in, as Matt Gates
said, even better, because we have the Second
Amendment and that's exactly what it should
be for.
Incredibly dangerous stuff, disgusting stuff.
But listen, if you're these people if you're
these right wingers, who's going to hold you
accountable?
No, we just we can't make any progress on
gun laws.
It's not really seeming like I mean, OK, there's
there's individuals being prosecuted for their
role in the Trump riots, but it's systemically.
Is there going to be any consequence?
It doesn't seem like it.
Why wouldn't you do it?
Make sure you're following me on Twitter.
Let me know your thoughts about this and also
make sure you're subscribed to the new YouTube
channel.
Yes, David Pakman dotcom slash Pakman live
new YouTube channel.
Totally different content.
I'm inviting you in.
The David Pakman Show, of course, is funded
mostly by great people like you who sign up
at Join Pakman Dotcom, if you wanted to take
advantage of the Memorial Day special and
you forgot or you missed the email or whatever
the code is, Memorial twenty one, the discount
is so aggressive, I'm embarrassed to even
say what it is on the show, so I won't.
OK, but that's the code memorial twenty one.
You can use it on the membership of your choice
at join Pakman dot com.